bonjour aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un
jeu rage en vous êtes content c'est bien
bravo d'avoir les autres souffrir c'est
bien aujourd'hui la maladie est à son
apogée donc j'ai zéro énergie et on va
quand même jouer un jeu rageant things
to die c'est un jeu dans lequel le but
est non pas de survivre aux piques aux
champignons qui te tue au nuage qui ont
fait trop souvent pic cette fois il est
question de mourir on saute
pourquoi du coup il me dois d'aller voir
les piques je pense que c'est 1,36 à
aller on va à la porte
voilà du coup on est mort parce qu'on
est allé à la part du connemara la
mauvaise façon donc il faut bien faire
un 3/6 nos scoops sur l'épique voilà
alors on va sur l'épique aussi ça oui
wright clic du web dans ce pays et ça
pour sauter d'accord ça permet de
retomber bien droit et d'arrêter
l'inertie ou try hard way falling of the
room ristar sur le maire d'auxi tourner
vers cette forme ça redémarre le niveau
c'est ça
d'accord ça ne suit pas celle othello
veste suivant des objets peuvent bouger
un peu plus voilà comme ça que tu me
tombe dessus et j'ai peur c'est sympa ce
jeu j'aime beaucoup le concept j'adore
mourir c'est la seule fois de ma vie où
j'ai j'ai aimé mourir que d'autres fois
je suis mort ne savait pas plus
excellent plat comment tu fais wathelet
robin alors varois reproduire le schéma
d'avant donc y en a un coût mais là
alors par dans quelque chose de fou
développer un violent pile sur l'autre
ouais et ensuite du coup on va faire
comme une ged avant juste poussé sud à
mourir donc qui va pas balla comment je
fais j'ai pas je peux pas double son
voile à penser avec vos yeux de calories
vers ce qu'on appelle leur hiver ses
volailles apporter invisible pronostics
a franchement hier j'étais tellement
fatiguée je passais 38 là dessus les
boutons peuvent faire des choses
d'accord ça va pas être un cube en face
au hockey du coup je peux monter et
mourir sympathie ces petites mécaniques
là ou là ou là ou là je prends part bon
alors on a tous compris
j'étais allé là avec sa la baume la
solution n'est pas toujours celle qu'on
force donc comment on fait là comment on
fait bordel de merde ça ça fait
apparaître ça ça va disparaître ça mais
la solution n'est pas toujours celle
qu'on pense donc peut-être qu'ils ont
mal an la ja paré la nôtre le cas je
peux pas aller là où ben voila voila ça
je me suis pris la tête à 1000% pourquoi
vous a fait chauffer on savoure ya là un
up on est bien super hop c'est débile
c'est lui qu'il faut mettre la balle lui
il faut mettre la lui que tu pousses
vous êtes tu peux accéder à lui hockey
comme ça tu peux pousser lui et mourir
waouh
c'était long tu es la casse tête chinois
bien pourquoi les casse-têtes songe
forcément chinois je viens c'est le seul
objet au monde où il est face aux
chinois je suis rentré malade
ensuite on fait disparaître les deux
cubes de là bas mais la solution n'est
pas toujours celle à laquelle on pense
ça c'est la mer par exemple je peux
faire tomber celui là ça fait tomber lui
et là j'ai accès à la plate-forme de
gauche qui me permet finalement de
sauter sur à ces super à solange plus
grand papa 6,6 ou c'est un bug dans un
bol là je passe c'est le même écart
entre les saguenéens pemex a abusé je
suis outré pu avec ce fonds qui bouge
tout seul là ça me donne la gerbe
est ce que je suis tombé voilà voilà la
solution n'est pas forcément là on le
pense méditer là dessus c'est moi qui
viens d'inventer ces faux alors et a3
d'âge
il ya trois dalles 4 puisque j'ai la
dalle aussi voilà c'est jingle blagues
nulles
ok je comprends le problème donc déjà on
va forcément a besoin de deux cuves de
quoi mettre plus là dessus
autant pouvant
pousser celui là mais il prend le cul je
peux pas le faire tomber à perdre donc
c'est faux en fait je peux pas le faire
tomber
ben voila je me disais bien lui
disparaît ce qui fait que du coup
normalement hop hop hop et les projets
sur lui et ensuite je peux amener subir
sur la dernière balle là je suis à un
stade où je t'ai manqué d'idées que
j'avais pu expliquer en même temps voilà
est-ce que je pourrais le professeur la
réponse est non c'est ça les pk pressée
pour cliquer sur le switch bouton âgés
change de mec rien d'égal saïda vous
souvenez inside d'accord nous faut que
tu les deux maintenant d'accord à ça
c'est super du coup tu fais quoi tu fais
ça ensuite tu pas sur lui et tu te tue
mais quand tu l'aube du coup à ok
j'aurais dû en fait allé là donc ça tue
j'ai compris j'aurais dû faire ça maître
lui là-dessus objets pièces salon je me
tue et merde un assez bon avec le
deuxième je fais ça amer je passais
poussé le cube d'accord ou pas sur ce
qu'on appelle finalement anne attardé
dans le milieu j'ai bien pu se voir mon
cas là je viens qu'à pousser le jeu ça
tombe et je me tue avec voilà
fantastique alors là qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire et quand frêche elle aussi
horrible je te mais voilà c'est réglé on
avait oublié l'histoire des portails
quand je vais pas me tuer je pense qu'il
faut juste que homo j'appuie en fait je
redescende aurais je pu sauter là est
incroyable ce bug ya deux secondes j'ai
sauvetage pourrait sauter vous n'êtes
pas commence à m'énerver schumann on n'a
pas que ça à faire
j'ai pris exprès un jeu où le but c'est
de mourir et vous faites quand même rage
et je me sens un petit peu trop les si
je puis me permettre
mais merde laisse moyal estompe les
belles baies et voilà ah ben là c'est
parfait c'est vraiment tout ce qu'on
voulait voir à voile à apurer au lose
you to john eiler gens reconnaissent son
de kylie minogue
on ne la changera pas pour le bien de
cette gorge asséché par la maladie iolo
je passe au deuxième c'est extrêmement
simple donc là on part là dessus ah oui
yes ouanna trigano gagne quoi c'est fini
non assassinés comme ça j'aurai te
laisses on galère sur le menu tu peux
pas tuer c'est bien c'est bien sa
torture les gens pas de souci et bien
voilà ce qu'a partie des 2 sur 6 e dan
n'hésitez pas à aller mais c'est vous a
plu je viens donner toute son énergie
dans cette phrase pour chaque live
j'aurai droit de prendre un doliprane
voilà du coup je vais décédé en une
minute comme il s'apprête avec ses lacs
là au nom puis mini micro du puits
demain il a quoi il à la petite grippe
aussi drôle mais je dois y en ait portez
vous bien et soignez vous bien si vous
aussi vous êtes malade à l'arrivée du
froid pourtant signé sûr pas le froid ne
sais pas pourquoi je suis à la merci au
regard des jo